l'analyse swot en cinq questions par
sylvain drammeh cours de formation
géographiques et sociales
retrouvez toutes les vidéos et tous les
travaux sur la société où loger au
qu'est-ce que une analyse faute soit
c'est l'acronyme de 4 mo strained
weaknesses opportunities and trade en
français ça donne les forces les
faiblesses les opportunités et les
menaces
à quoi sert une analyse soude une
analyse soit vous permettra d'évaluer
l'attractivité d'un territoire
une analyse vos hôtes vous permettra
d'évaluer la pertinence d'un projet ou
d'une idée une analyse souhaite vous
permettra d'évaluer une campagne de
publicité de communication voire de peau
plus politiques publiques
une analyse ou autre vous permettra
enfin d'évaluer la pertinence d'un
produit pour un marché le lancement
d'une nouvelle marque ou toute action
marketing vous voyez qu'une analyse soit
hôte peut être utilisé dans de nombreux
domaines pour de nombreux objectifs
comment ça marche une analyse saute une
analyse haute vous aurez des éléments
positifs et négatifs dans les éléments
positifs tout d'abord vous allez noter
l'ensemble des éléments que vous trouvez
positif pour la réussite de votre projet
et qui ont une origine interne c'est à
dire qu'ils sont intrinsèques au projet
on va appeler cela les forces les
éléments qui peuvent être positifs pour
la réussite de votre projet mais qui ont
une origine externes c'est-à-dire sur
lesquels vous n'avez aucune prise
vous les considérez dans la case
opportunité vous y mettrez également
tous les éléments qui ne sont pas encore
présents mais qui pourrait voir le jour
durant la réalisation du projet tous les
éléments potentiels qui peuvent être
positifs dans un deuxième temps vous
vous attacherez a complété la colonne
négatif les éléments négatifs qui vont
peut-être faire que votre corps projet
sera un échec et qui sont propres à
votre projet vous les mettez dans la
case faiblesse les éléments qui peuvent
être préjudiciables pour votre projet
mais qui sont d'origine externe
c'est à dire sur lesquels vous n'avez
aucune prise vous les considérez dans la
colonne négatif mais cette fois ci dans
la case menace il en ira de même pour
tous les éléments négatifs qui son
potentiel c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont
pas encore présents mais qui pourraient
survenir dans le futur vous voyez que la
mise en oeuvre d'une analyse swot et
rapide
toutefois ne vous attendez pas à
compléter directement toutes les cases
d'une seule fois il vaut mieux y revenir
régulièrement pour amender vos idées et
pour compléter les différents éléments
déjà consignée la quatrième question que
nous allons nous poser quant à l'analyse
swot et quand est ce que je dois
réaliser cette analyse je ne vous
répondrai pas directement puisque vous
pouvez réaliser cette analyse à tout
moment c'est à dire avant le projet
avant de lancer pour évaluer simplement
sa pertinence et voir si ça vaut le coup
si le jeu en vaut la chandelle de se
lancer dans ce projet là
vous pourrez réaliser l'analyse faute
pendant la réalisation du projet afin de
recadrer éventuellement les éléments qui
pourraient nuire à la réussite finale de
ce projet et enfin vous pouvez la
réaliser une évaluation finale pour
évaluer bien sûr si votre projet peut
être considérée comme réussie ou comme
un échec
voici un très bel exemple d' analyse
soit qui nous est proposée par kathleen
van hover mère qui travaille pour le
compte de l'union des villes et des
communes wallonnes qui a réalisé une
étude sur l'attractivité touristique de
la commune de chiny florenville cette
étude date de décembre 2013 elle est
bien sûr consultable à l'adresse qui est
affiché à l'écran nous allons prendre
quelques exemples vous pourrez parcourir
bien sûr à votre aise l'ensemble de
l'étude
on se pose la question pour ce
territoire de chiny florenville quels
sont les atouts touristiques
vous voyez que la première chose et le
patrimoine naturel exceptionnel de la
région avec la semoy des massifs
forestiers une faune et une flore
intéressante
ce sont vraiment les qualités propres du
tourisme de la région
les gens qui viennent bien de chercher
des éléments là évidemment
quant aux faiblesses du projet qui sont
internes à ce projet touristique c'est
le peu d'infrastructures qui permettent
de profiter du patrimoine exceptionnel
dont on vient de parler
évidemment il ne tient qu'à la commune
de chiny florenville de réaliser des
aires de repos pour les touristes
d'aménager les berges de la semoy et de
valoriser la faune et la flore locales
au niveau des éléments externes cette
fois ci quant aux opportunités
quelles sont elles on va tout d'abord
considérer qu'il ya un élément très
positif sur lequel la commune de chiny
florenville n'a aucune prise mais qui va
jouer pour si vous voulez le
développement touristique le
développement local de la commune
c'est l'évolution de la demande vers un
tourisme plus vert au niveau sociétal
beaucoup de gens veulent revenir à la
nature et vont donc être très ouverte à
venir dans une commune comme celle là au
niveau des menaces
on peut noter ici le perte la perte
d'attractivité touristique du terroir
c'est à dire l'image de cette commune
par rapport à des communes environnantes
a vraiment perdu de sa superbe et
certains touristes délaisse cette
commune actuellement pour d'autres
communes
évidemment la commune de chiny
florenville n'a aucune prise sur
l'attractivité que peut avoir les
communes extérieures
si la commune d'à côté jouy vraiment
d'une plus belle réputation chiny
florenville ne peut rien y faire c'est
pour cette raison qu'on place cet
élément dans les menaces extérieures
enfin pour être complet vous aurez noté
que dans cette analyse présente la case
force a été remplacé par la case à tous
évidemment ils s'ajustent juste d'une
substitution
parce qu'on utilise parfois l'acronyme
de afom en français pour franciser le
terme soute
je vous remercie de votre attention vous
avez ici différentes coordonnées qui
vous permettent éventuellement de poser
vos questions pour aller plus loin merci
et à bientôt